so the girl i want to couple up with is
justine
[Music]
hey rachel i am shocked i am shocked how
are you feeling
honestly like i didn't i would say i
like didn't expect it for sure
um but like honestly you you kind of
come out of it and like you're able to
like think things through and like okay
well
i guess this made sense and this made
sense and this made sense like
um i think initially i was really really
shocked um
and then it was like you know you have
to go with the connection that you feel
is like the strongest so yeah it's
kind of it like sucked watching i felt
like you and justine got pitted against
each other a lot during the course of
the show
like was that frustrating for you
absolutely
like that was i don't think we were like
necessarily hitting against each other
it just
ended up working out that way where we
like
i mean i think that were
struggle to use like the words similar
but i just think that like we have like
almost have like the same kind of
like energy or like vibe and like i
think we have the same
type which is why like we were
constantly kind of ending up
um with the overlap but yeah
yeah i mean because you guys had you
guys kind of were going after the same
guy two different times
and one it was like you were kind of
going after her guy and then she was
going after your guy so
you kind of had this conversation where
you like friend broke up with her
but how are you feeling now well i mean
looking back it was one of those things
where i like almost resent
the idea that like i like went after
jeremiah like i just like went on a date
with like a guy in the villa and like we
just like really hit it off and the way
it was like presented to me was that it
was like
over completely and so i think that the
only time we really like
were really like openly pursuing the
same person was
with caleb so well it was like
during the challenge i was on one hand i
was like go justine like go for what you
want because we've kind of seen her kind
of hold herself back throughout the show
but then
as your friend i was like what this is
the first time we're even hearing that
she's interested in caleb did you have
any inclination that she was into him
you know like there were conversations
but it was like
she would just tell me how much caleb
liked me and like
she would just tell me like oh he talked
about you the whole time like after the
challenge we like had a conversation and
she was just like
you know we like both kind of were like
laughing during the kiss and i was like
i don't think so like yeah
and i i was shocked that caleb picked
justine even during his speech i thought
he was picking you
until like he said the word justine so
did you feel a [ __ ]
with caleb at all you know i think like
looking back things definitely like made
more sense i think that
um there was like he he felt like second
best and like
those were kind of like the nature of
our conversations was like he felt like
you know um even with like pursuing
just like it was i think he it was one
of those things very sorry i'm like kind
of like okay well it was like this
but it was like this the problem with
like love island is you're like you can
see
all the sides of it and like you know
everyone is just there for their own
experience
um but i definitely think that um
you know it just kind of like was what
it was like i think that it's like
i think that during that speech i was
definitely i did not expect to go home
like when i went home um that being said
like
it's hard to fault him or fault hurt
like it's just a tough situation
so yeah so what do you think about them
as a couple do you wish them well do you
think they'll be successful
i really hope that they are successful
and i do wish them well because i think
that everyone there is
so incredible and like really does
deserve to find love um
and i don't know i think it's hard
because i think that
um i think that they are like a better
fit
as far as like moving forward um
but i think if you ask trey what's gonna
happen is that
um i i hope that like they continue to
grow
yeah i really felt like trey was trying
to get her off the show
yeah i think i think that's
that's accurate uh but we we saw you two
kind of embrace and say goodbye at the
end
do you feel like you and justine can
will be friends
after this experience probably not
i think that at this point it's one of
those things where it's like you meet
people and you
you know you get along with them and i
really do wish her the best
i just think that you know like i just
i definitely think like moving forward i
was just closer with
other islanders had less conflict and
like i don't really want to like work
through a bunch of things so like we can
stay friends like i
you know it's it's okay to not be
friends totally i
i love that i love the honesty who would
you say you were closest with in the
villa
uh i think um it's so funny because
i really liked everyone for like
different reasons and i felt close
in different ways um but i think like
overall
like favorites were definitely kirsten
because we came in together
and yeah and just because like i spent
so much time with pierce and i ended up
getting to know carrington really well
and then honestly trey was really cool
like the entire time
so um and that being said i didn't know
her that well or like i didn't get to
spend that much time with her but
i really liked lauren but also i really
liked everyone like it's like okay well
i loved moe and i loved connor and i
love kenzie like
you know and so all together it's
definitely
i just love everyone what did you think
of lauren coming into the villa
i loved it like i was really i was
excited that she came in
i think that it was like one of the
things that makes love island so great
is that things are
constantly changing so i was excited to
have her in the villa she was super cool
and from great style so
mackenzie definitely reacted to
uh her going on a date with connor i'm
very curious because you seem pretty
close with mckenzie like you were the
one that really hit her with
some truth that i think no one else was
willing to tell her
yeah so how do you feel about her and
connor
you know i think it's one of those
things where it's it's really just up to
the two of them as far as like
what it looks like moving forward i
think that
at least the time that i spend together
is they seem to make each other
better um that being said um
some things came to light that night but
you know it it definitely is kind of
like
you know i'm gonna let them figure that
one out it was
it was so confused because we were all
like you know i feel like everyone
watching was like mackenzie's being kind
of controlling
then america sent connor on this date
with lauren but then he comes back and
connor turns into like
a boy where he's like doesn't want to
tell her how he feels and then he's like
my girlfriend actually never mind i want
to i want to break up
and like i was like connor what are you
doing
yeah it's it's hard because it's like i
think it's
you know every every relationship every
problem that's in a relationship is
i think 50 50. so it's hard because it's
like i think
yeah kenzie can be a little dominant in
her relationships but at the same time
like connor
you feel that way you gotta tell her
like that was so frustrating to watch
um i'm curious your thoughts on sally
and johnny too because
i don't know if you guys were privy to
this but johnny went on a date with
lauren and said that she
was turning his head and i was like i
thought that sally and johnny were very
strong they went to the hideaway they
seemed like one of the strongest couples
but
it seems to me like sally's more into
johnny than
johnny's into celly do you think that's
accurate
i think that you kind living in the
house is a little bit different because
you you get to see people at all times i
think that
johnny does really care about sally um
if i had to say who i think cares more
about who i would probably say
i think sally's a little bit more
interested in johnny yeah
but yeah we'll see what happens when
maybe another guy will come in
exactly only i will tell
uh so since you get to spend so much
time with them who do you think is the
strongest
couple in the house right now i honestly
kind of like helen and mo together
like i think really like each other for
the like
right reasons yeah and it just seems
like they kind of have like this natural
chemistry and like
in the villa like he just took such good
care of her that you know
it was just so sweet to watch he seems
really sweet like when he first came on
show i was like uh who is this
and then i was like he's really nice
yeah he's
really nice and like i was i was having
a conversation with caleb one time and
um we were just kind of like what is it
about calvin and caleb said like he's
got swag
and it's surprising like so
yeah he's a really cool guy you said you
and justine will probably not be friends
after this
what about you and caleb do you guys
think you could be friends after this
honestly looking back i'm glad
okay it's weird to say like okay i'm
glad that he chose
justine like i'm not glad that like that
meant that i had to go home like i would
have loved to stay
but at the same time it's like i think
looking back
i was really excited to be caleb's
[Music]
friend